bonsoir thomas alors face à la percée
des talibans en afghanistan le
gouvernement américain ne semble pas
remettre en question finalement le
départ des troupes du pays comment
réagissent les autorités américaines à
la situation sur place
mais en fait on a deux versions il ya
d'abord évidemment la version officielle
mais il ya aussi cette version qu'on a
notamment pu lire dans les colonnes du
washington post qui cite des sources
anonymes et on sent poindre une forme
d'inquiétude parmi ces sources proches
du dossier des personnes qui travaillent
vraisemblablement au sein de
l'administration de la maison blanche
ces personnes ces sources elle estime
par exemple que kaboul pourraient tomber
aux mains des talibans bien plus vite
que ce qui était initialement prévu par
les services de renseignement américains
on parle d'un mois voire 90 jours avant
que la capitale afghane ne soit donc
occupées par les forces armées des
talibans alors évidemment il ya
maintenant cette question qui a été
posée d'ailleurs au président américain
joe biden est ce qu'il regrette sa
décision de retirer les troupes
américaines d'afghanistan écoutez sa
réponse
non écoutés nous avons dépensé plus de
mille milliards de dollars sur 20 ans
nous avons formé et équipé plus de
300000 forces afghanes avec du matériel
moderne et les dirigeants afghans doit
s'unir
nous avons perdu des milliers et des
milliers de personnels américain des
milliers de morts et de blessés ils
doivent se battre pour eux mêmes se
battre pour leur nation
les états unis insisterons pour que nous
continuons à tenir les engagements que
nous avons pris en fournissant un
soutien aérien rapproché en veillant à
ce que les forces aériennes fonctionne
et soit opérationnel on
réapprovisionnant leurs forces en
nourriture et en équipements et en
payant tout leur salaire mais il faut
qu'ils aient envie de se battre ils sont
plus nombreux que les talibans et je
reçois des briefings quotidiens
je pense qu'il ya encore une possibilité
ils ont un nouveau secrétaire à la
défense important
autre équivalent du secrétaire à la
défense en afghanistan ismaïl khan qui
est un combattant sérieux je pense
qu'ils commencent à réaliser qu'ils
doivent s'unir politiquement au sommet
mais nous allons continuer à tenir notre
engagement mais je ne regrette pas ma
décision
vous l'avez entendu aucun regret de la
part du président américain joe biden
est en réalité pour le gouvernement des
états unis ce n'est pas inéluctable que
les talibans prennent possession d'une
majorité du territoire en afghanistan il
ya par exemple net price le porte-parole
de la diplomatie américaine qui a lui
aussi rappelé que les forces armées
afghanes étaient plus nombreuses que les
talibans et qu'elle était entraînée et
soutenu logistiquement par les forces
armées américaines mais la réalité du
terrain elle vient elle est un peu
différente parce qu on comprend aussi
que les talibans prennent possession
d'un certain nombre d'armes que
possèdent les forces gouvernementales et
on voit aussi les témoignages affluent
et de soldats de l'armée afghane qui
quittent leurs fonctions par peur
justement est bien de ses offensives des
talibans dans le pays la crainte en
réalité c'est un scénario qui pourrait
être un scénario similaire à celui de
l'irak en 2011 rappelez-vous à l'époque
les forces armées américaines s'étaient
retirés du pays mais avait dû se
redéployer quelques années plus tard
parce que il y avait les émergences de
l'état islamique dans le pays alors
évidemment cette situation n'est pas
encore sait pas encore ce qui se passe
en afghanistan on en est loin mais s'il
ya une situation de chaos avec des
conséquences qui pourraient finalement
être assez similaire à celle qu'on a
connue en irak c'est par exemple ce
qu'affirme une chercheuse afghane qui
est cité cette fois dans les colonnes du
new york times elle explique que les
états unis n'ont pas permis
l'établissement d'une stabilité
politique en afghanistan et que
finalement les autorités afghanes sont
encore très dépendante des états unis et
que le départ plutôt soudain des forces
armées affaiblit considérablement
justement le poids de ces autorités
afghanes en tout cas donc pas de retour
en arrière pour le moment de la part de
joe biden on verra si la stratégie est
adapté au cours des prochaines semaines
vous l'avez entendu il suit un briefing
quotidien sur la situation en
afghanistan il pourrait peut-être y
avoir d ajuster sur l'appui logistique
notamment l'appui aérien fourni par les
états unis mais il faut bien comprendre
que ce retrait des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan
eh bien il est validé largement par
l'opinion ici aux etats unis merci
beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas bonnin en direct de
washington